well ted with temperatures this high
chances are you probably clicked on the
ac and this is really the best time to
check it before it gets too hot already
this week repair companies are getting
lots of calls madison kimbrough tells us
what you need to know when you turn to
cool
while we're approaching those scorching
summer months technicians say getting
your ac unit checked ahead of season is
a make or break situation literally
we're fan people i believe there's a fan
in every room an overhead fan and then i
was born and raised in the south so i'm
used to having the ac quite high
across the valley many homeowners like
betsy joyce cook are making the call to
hvac technicians for service places like
bumble breeze have been busy with house
calls all this week derrick thompson
says the calls are ongoing we're going
to do a spring tune-up on both of her
systems today we'll check all the
components all of the electrical
components her compressor her fan motors
make sure they're in range their
amperage is correct
just this week the company serviced over
a hundred homes and thompson says the
key to maintaining a good ac system is
routine checkups but also having a
certain type of thermostat helps too
what we recommend is actually getting a
thermostat that will put up be put on
geo fencing meaning when you come within
about let's say two miles of your home
it'll click your thermostat on and and
cool your house to your just designated
temperature obviously you do not want
your system running all day when you're
not there joyce cook says she gets
routine maintenance done yearly and with
her working from home a working ac is a
must it's really critical for us to have
cool air
we have two really small kids
and so obviously very heat sensitive as
for keeping your home cool but not
breaking the bank it's recommended to
keep your thermostat within the mid 70s
you can also use a ceiling fan and
remember to keep your blinds closed
reporting in henderson madison kimbrough
live local now